les médecins ont ouvert à montréal il ya
quelques jours une première clinique
médicale offrant la possibilité de
prescrire de la marijuana thérapeutique
depuis que le gouvernement du canada a
décidé l'an dernier de se départir de
son programme de marijuana médicale
il a dans les faits autorisé des
producteurs commerciaux à fournir
directement la marijuana à des patients
michel bonsoir sont donc maintenant les
médecins qui vont devoir donner accès à
7,7 marijuana thérapeutique médicale en
signant une ordonnance a créé des remous
ça dans la profession oui ça crée des
remous de boire avant tout parce que
c'est une substance illégale c'est en
fait la substance la plus consommée au
monde entre 120 millions et 220 millions
d'adultes en consomment
mais il ya la petite histoire du
cannabis médical qui est intéressante en
fait
jusque dans les années 1940 aux états
unis par exemple c'était légal ça
faisait partie de la pharmacopée
officielle du pays on s'en servait pour
la douleur pour d'autres pour d'autres
problèmes et il ya eu comme une chasse à
la sorcière effectivement dans les
années 40 30 et 40 qui a fait en sorte
qu' on a mis ça sous la loi des
narcotiques on avait peur que les gens
se lancent sur l'héroïne s'il prenait
delà de la marijuana
donc ce fait en sorte que dans
l'ensemble des pays on a très peu fait
de recherche médicale parce que c'était
illégal d'en faire donc peu de recherche
qu'est ce qu'on sait précisément sur les
effets thérapeutiques de cette manière
houanard bon alors la marijuana comme
tel à certains bénéfices qui ont été
mesurées dans des études cliniques
donc on peut mieux contrôler maintenant
avec ça la douleur dans nom de
nombreuses maladies on peut également
mieux contrôler le vomissement et les
nausées chez les cancéreux qui sont en
chimiothérapie et pour les sidéens
sanglante limpide si donc on a des
études mais qui sont selon les médecins
sur de petites cohortes sur dd durée
trop courte pour avoir un effet mais de
plus en plus de malaisie scellier mais
regardons ensemble sur le tableau vous
allez voir il y en a beaucoup on trouve
une amélioration des symptômes l'asthme
le comble c'est rose en plaques
mais la fibromyalgie il ya un à un
1 à le tableau va se remplir alors les
messins se pose des questions savoir
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire et donc
justement comment vont-ils faire
prescrire 7 marijuana ben c'est pas si
c'est pas évident en fait et il ya cette
collège des médecins provinciaux qui ont
demandé des questions très clair avant
de faire l'ordonance parce que là haut
les médecins trouvent que la science
n'est pas très clair tout d'abord les
indications qu'elle marijuana pour
quelle maladie le dosage est ce que
c'est une deux trois cigarettes qu'il
faut pour commencer à avoir un effet
thérapeutique les interactions avec les
autres médicaments que l'école des
passants peuvent prendre et les effets
nuisibles à long terme tout ça est pas
encore mal définie est encore mal
définie
comment les médecins vont s'en sortir
michel a bien écouté il ya quand même
une bonne une bonne chose dans cette
dans cette aventure là c'est que là
enfin on pourra faire la recherche
il ya un an il ya déjà de recherche
clinique en cours au canada est bon il
faut se le dire je crois que les
médecins vont être prudents vont donner
uniquement aux gens qui ne peuvent pas
être soignés par d'autres traitements
plus classique
il ya quand même trente sept mille
canadiens qui ont droit en 2014
d'utiliser la marijuana très la fête ses
dix ans après c'est quand même beaucoup
alors je crois qu'avec l'ouverture des
cliniques on en verra probablement
beaucoup plus dans les prochaines années
c'est fort intéressant merci beaucoup
oui cher mais on s'est beaucoup de
civils